[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginate di aver vissuto la vostra
quarantena nella giungla tra animali
caldo umido e tormente di pioggia
immaginate un attimo in che modo
l'isolamento vi ha messo la prova e come
avete interagito con la natura selvaggia
circostante immaginate ora immaginate
che la giungla sia la vostra vita e che
in questo momento storico abbiamo
l'opportunità di riscoprire nuovi in
stili di vita più in armonia per la
nostra natura interiore ed esteriore
mi chiamo lorenzo olivieri sono un
esploratore e da oggi voglio invitarvi
in un viaggio verso una nuova
consapevolezza che arriva dalla giungla
dove ho vissuto la mia quarantena per
tre mesi un ecovillaggio con trenta
persone che arrivavano da 16 nazioni
differenti
siete pronti bene partiamo da un fatto
oltre 5 milioni di italiani ogni giorno
acquistano gratta e vinci dalle fonti
istat tra cui uno dei biglietti più
gettonati sono quelli che si chiamano
turista per sempre
immaginate che meraviglia da domani non
dovete più andare al lavoro
potete viaggiare facendovi selphy nei
luoghi più belli al mondo è una favola
allo stesso tempo nel mondo esistono
circa 21.000 non turisti ma esploratori
che viaggiando danno vita a circa 6.000
micro comunità che vivono in eco
villaggi questo dalle fonti di global
village network ma cos'è un ecovillaggio
da una comunità basata sulla
sostenibilità ambientale si basa sulla
adesione volontaria dei partecipanti
uniti dagli stessi valori ed ideali
energie che vengono quindi
dell'alternativa come i pannelli solari
nuclei abitativi che si basano sulla
bioarchitettura e la bioedilizia
autosufficienza basata sull'agricoltura
biologica se la permacultura questi
sembrano due concetti totalmente opposti
ma se facciamo attenzione in questi
minuti li faremo incontrare
così in piccolo anche grande scopriremo
che alcuni delle potenziali soluzioni ai
cambiamenti climatici arrivano proprio
da questa vita virtuosa queste micro
comunità in ecovillaggi prima di farlo
studiamo un attimo le caratteristiche di
un turista spiaggia per periodi brevi fa
foto e acquista souvenir e andando ad
appropriarsi in maniera maldestra e
superficiale della cultura locale
alloggia in hotel di medio alto livello
che fanno sempre capo d'azienda
internazionale quindi circolare i propri
capitali fuori delle aziende visitate
anch'io prima del 2010 erano tra queste
persone poi la mia la vita mi ha dato
l'opportunità di cambiare direzione e
diventare un esploratore
ma cosa fa un esploratore
per scoprirlo vi racconto la mia
esperienza personale che il 2015 ho
intrapreso il mio primo viaggio
esplorativo verso le lontane culture
delle ande ispirato da un libro di
elizabeth jenkins ritorno dell'inca
insieme al mio amico jacopo zaino in
spalla abbiamo esplorato tutta la sacra
valle di cusco alla ricerca della
spiritualità andina e stato un viaggio
che si è trasformato da esplorativo a
mistico la cosa abbiamo fatto di diverso
dai turisti classici e hanno continuato
a guidare gruppi in sui luoghi sacri e
spirituali nel mondo anche siamo rimasti
più a lungo nel tempo nei luoghi che
abbiamo esplorato ed hanno creato degli
scambi culturali tra le popolazioni
locali
noi esploratori anche attraverso dei
festival e quando questo accade si
creano delle microcomunità che creano
appunto degli altri villaggi
ma andiamo ancora più in profondità e
conosciamo un'altra storia di un altro
esploratore questa volta un po più
antico si chiama airam bingham è stato
conosciuto come lo scopritore del machu
picchu nel 1911 ma in realtà cos'è
accaduto quando bingham è salito in
questa montagna sacra già esistevano dei
contadini peruviani che vivevano in cui
le ande lui semplicemente quando è
tornato negli stati uniti
ha pubblicato queste sua scoperta con la
national geographic society e questo ha
reso famoso in tutto il mondo
questo luogo sacro che è diventato
patrimonio dell'umanità sancito
dall'unesco
ma cosa è diventato grazie al turismo
nel 2016
circa cinquemila persone al giorno
loro hanno visitata negli anni
successivi il governo un peruviano
deciso che la situazione era
insostenibile ma cpc si stava
deteriorando
così ha limitato l'accesso solo a 2.500
persone sempre il giorno questo problema
è nato dal fatto che negli ultimi
decenni i voli sono diventati
accessibili a gran parte della
popolazione mondiale nel 1990
viaggiavamo del mondo un miliardo di
persone dalle fonti di rainews nel 2016
3,5 miliardi
questo aumentato moltissimo il turismo
di massa mordi e fuggi anche
internazionale quindi come possiamo
continuare ad esplorare ai giorni d'oggi
senza andare ad intaccare impattare
negativamente le popolazioni e le
culture locali
esiste un'alternativa a questo scopriamo
insieme qua e per stupito che racconto
questa curiosa quarantena che ho vissuto
nella giungla a febbraio di questo anno
dice l'ho deciso di spostarmi dalle ande
peruviane e dove vivono per sei mesi
all'anno per un ritiro spirituale in una
remota spiaggia di panama
proprio nelle due settimane in cui nel
mondo è scattato la pandemia è scoppiata
la pandemia dal 1 al 18 marzo alla fine
del ritiro
la polizia panamense non mi ha permesso
di ritornare in perù e sono rimasto
bloccato a panama è stata un'avventura
un mix tra panico e magia
stavamo rischiando di rimanere bloccati
a panama city tra i grattacieli quando
proprio grazie a delle microcomunità che
conosciamo abbiamo scoperto un
ecovillaggio nella giungla
e stata la nostra salvezza ci siamo
ritrovati in comunità
abbiamo iniziato per interagire tra gli
animali natura circostante il caldo
pazzesco ma con un vestiario minimo ci
siamo subito messi al lavoro per trovare
delle soluzioni alle problematiche
perché avevamo nelle come l'aggio la
sera parlavamo intorno al fuoco
raccontandoci le nostre gioie le nostre
sofferenze momenti particolari danzava
mo danzavano insieme raggiungendo con un
estasi rituale capace di infrangere i
nostri limiti che separano le nostre
personalità individuali ciò che
ricerchiamo in questo momento storico
sono nuove comunità di affinità elettive
questa è stata una delle esperienze più
significative della mia vita fino ad ora
e mi ha ispirato a trasformare il mio
stile di vita in uno più sostenibile
perché molto spesso nelle nostre vite
siamo molto più inquieti di quello che
dovremmo essere nelle nostre case
siamo un po appesantiti da qualcosa come
di grande che ci manca nelle nostre vite
questo qualcosa e un senso di comunità
come ha detto anche thomas torelli un
tempo l'essere umano era una creatura
tribale
ora non lo siamo più viviamo in comunità
virtuali e nessuno pure in pochi si
prendono l'impegno di ripensare dire
scoprire nuovi modi di vivere e
dileggiare quindi visto che in pochi lo
fanno
facciamo loro a noi qua immaginiamo cosa
significa vivere una comunità ideale
vivremo in una serie di edifici
ecologici in campagna una città nella
giungla sulle ande uniti da degli spazi
comuni dove potremo cooperare in maniera
reciproca e insieme troveremo nuove
opportunità scopriremo appunto nove tipi
di lavori anche appunto quello che
stiamo cercando sono nuove comunità di
attività elettive perché questo
perché l'essere umano in questo momento
storico si può permettere di vivere
questo tipo di esperienza
ok io mi rendo conto di essere
un'eccezione e molte persone con i figli
un lavoro fisso tiranno e lorenzo mica
posso venire nella giungla con te certo
non dovete viaggiare tutti come me anche
se alcuni lo fanno per viaggio di cui vi
parlo oggi della nostra consapevolezza
che può essere può partire anche dalle
nostre città ok per superare cambiamenti
climatici possiamo eliminare le
bottigliette di plastica bene possiamo
acquistare in gruppi solidali bene
qualche modo possiamo creare nuove
azioni ancora più virtuose che ora
neanche ci immaginiamo ad esempio questo
quest'estate tornato dalla giungla
insieme agli esploratori che viaggiano
con noi abbiamo fatto il giro degli
ecovillaggi l'italia allora stiamo
facendo delle prove di comunità dei
laboratori in cui prendere queste buone
azioni e portarle nelle nostre vite
questo può essere fatto si sa che ha un
lavoro fisso ma in città ha dei figli
un week end e prendersi qualche giorno
anzi invito a farlo anche a voi
alla fine di questo incontro cercate
laico villaggio più vicino a casa vostra
e visitatelo semplicemente internet e
vedere le buone azioni che si vivono
come si interagisce con la natura come
si come si vive con l'altra altre
persone all'interno di un eco villaggio
ma quali sono queste azioni si basano su
quattro indicazioni principali che sono
la base in un ecovillaggio riduci riusa
ricicla e coopera immaginiamo
semplicemente se prendiamo una dopo
l'altra
queste azioni e le portiamo nelle nostre
vite
che differenza possiamo fare tutti
quanti nel mondo in un canto astremo più
gli andamenti climatici non andremo più
contro un sistema ma queste nuove azioni
saranno capaci di creare una nuova
società un nuovo sistema differente
capace appunto di creare delle
microcomunità cooperative tra di loro
che renderanno la vecchia visione del
turista obsoleta e ci farà sentire a
casa
in tutto il mondo e queste buone azioni
stanno creando anche una nuova visione
del senso di casa sia tra noi
esploratori che tra le nuove generazioni
infatti tornando al confronto iniziale
un turista vede casa le proprie quattro
mura noi esploratori e molte delle nuove
generazioni che viaggiano vedono casa
tutta quella serie di luoghi uniti da un
filo rosso di buone relazioni capaci di
farci sentire in connessione tra le
nostre radici le nostre ali quindi tra
la terra e il cielo in fondo la
connessione tra la terra e il cielo è
l'essere umano
e se in questo momento storico in cui i
voli internazionali sono limitati fosse
una grande opportunità di trasformare il
nostro modo di vivere e di viaggiare di
trasformare anche la nostra idea di casa
delle nostre quattro mura al mondo
intero come cambierà la nostra vita
le nuove generazioni non compreranno più
gratta e vinci per diventare turista per
sempre ma tratteremo via i nostri limiti
che avevamo di fronte agli occhi per
trasformarci in esploratori per tutta la
vita
[Applauso]